هذه صور حية، هذه هي
المرة الأولى التي نراها جميعًا لدانيلو
كافالكانتي وهو محتجز، جون يشرح لنا
ما تراه هنا
أرى فريق التدخل السريع وهو على الأرجح
الأشخاص الذين احتجزوه وأرى
رجلاً لديه  تغيير الملابس
التي لسنا على دراية بها والتي هي
قميص من النوع الثقيل الجديد وبنطلون داكن، كانت هناك
تقارير تفيد بأنه تم
العثور على حقيبة ظهر بين عشية وضحاها تحتوي على أشياء
بداخلها وأشياء من الملابس وما إلى ذلك ربما
كانت خاصة به  ما
دفعهم إلى منطقة معينة لكنه
كان يقوم بهذا النوع من عمليات
اقتحام المنازل والسطو والمرآب، كما
تعلمون، ويحاولون العثور على
ملابس مختلفة لمواصلة تغيير مظهره،
كما تعلمون أن تقريرنا الأخير
كان بلا قميص، لذا من الواضح أنه كان يرتدي
هذه الملابس  يختبئ أثناء اختبائه ولكن
يمكنك معرفة أنه حتى وهو يمشي
هو رجل منهك من هذه
الرحلة